[Music]
stupid [ __ ] backpackers do news I'll let
it bye love you I mean backpackers have
started begging to fund their trip in
Southeast Asia and the locals are not
happy about that why the trash in the
place aren't they they're not trashing
the place it's just that for you to go
ahead and beg or like you know play
music or just like offer like they're
begging to go on a vacation when these
guys barely have to eat exactly oh wait
they're in Southeast Asia they're
currently in chopping so they're taking
the jobs of the other panhandlers that
are actually poor well in order to
Panhandle there you would need to have
like permits yeah permit where are they
panhandling like in Thailand ursin or
what are these all over in Southeast
Asia
you can't ask someone else warning you
for money Kong dude so they're [ __ ]
like playing the guitar like well
there's an actual person with no legs
dragging their body asking for change in
Thailand yeah I cut the legs off or
something yeah we were in Venice and
yeah like I saw that I saw that
happening I'm like why are you like he
had a hat in front of him I'm trying to
get rich man Italy or Venice yeah
your [ __ ] hand handling to vacation
yeah annals and he was like super well
dress or you've hair done really nice
his backpack like backpacking backpack
in his guitar and like yeah like a hat
right there in front it like to get
money and I'm like why that makes sense
in Italy though but like in a
third-world country why would they give
you money if they need to already
struggling yeah they gotta feed their
kids at night so locals in Southeast
Asia they're saying that yeah like what
you're saying tourists are taking money
from those who truly need it and they're
just saying that like you're mocking the
way that that's all you know to see the
world and my son has no food because
because they just like traveling is more
of a love is a luxury it is 100% Amon
got themself
there yep and they got they ran out of
money there that's costing get a job and
in order to Panhandle there it's only
visitors who have worked visas that are
allowed to do if you're just traveling
you can't even Panhandle but it's in
Southeast Asia like the cheapest
the world to my Kylie ran out of money
because the [ __ ] dog dude I think if
I was a farmer and I'm working my
[ __ ] ass off every day and I see this
[ __ ] white guy like just begging for
money I would take my [ __ ] sickle and
I was stabbed in the [ __ ] Danny
became this is no because I'm struggling
every [ __ ] day right and then you are
on a vacation just a backpack through my
country you want to take my money yeah
that everyone's working hard as [ __ ] and
you're just asking for exactly the
audacity dude that like what the whole
experience me right hey hey there
they're working they're playing music
okay they're entertaining to work on
these nuts [ __ ] they can become a sex
worker Oh that'll be great or even just
pick up a javac sweeping someone's
restaurant or something else I'll teach
English how to score some [ __ ] yeah you
[ __ ] [ __ ] that's really low that's
like going to Somalia and then like
there's all these kids begging and you
[ __ ] push them to the side and then
you start tap dancing put your hat on
the floor and [ __ ] one person from
Singapore what the hell are you doing
we'll see you poor doctor what country
see Singapore is a respectable
modern-day country in Southeast Asia
most millionaires well this person from
Singapore she's saying first of all you
don't see many people selling
knickknacks or playing music in the
street in Singapore because there are
strict rules governing these activities
and if you do happen to see street
vendors or street performers they're
usually in the town centre and not near
a bus stop in a relatively middle-class
neighborhood like this I've also never
seen white people doing that we find it
extremely strange to ask other people
for money to help you travel selling
things in the street or begging isn't
considered respectable people who do so
are really in need they beg in order to
buy food pay the chosen school fees or
pay often the term responsible [ __ ] but
not in order to do something seen as a
luxury they should kick their asses out
yeah they should check that also the
[ __ ] country dude [ __ ] piece of
[ __ ] yeah so then she continues to say I
want to ask these tourists what makes
you think that this kind of behavior is
normal in Asia why don't you do the same
thing at home which is what you're
literally saying you scare some pictures
of people it is only in Singapore they
just say Singapore or Malaysia and I
believe also Vietnam as well
they did in Thailand and surprised the
police and come on and beat their ass
yeah I don't Singapore they should get
their asses [ __ ] up that's [ __ ]
ridiculous
so they're sitting around support our
trip they're not in really like
impoverished nations though Singapore
you know being hot please sir I am
traveling around Asia without money
please support my trip what kind of
[ __ ] entitled [ __ ] is that I bet
you these are [ __ ] dumbass rich kids
that don't know how to manage their
money that ran out of funds doesn't help
me like you're on your own you [ __ ]
yeah so Balin Danna shows how ignorant
they really are to the [ __ ] offenses
it's put an actual sign thing like
support our trip I hope to god they're
not American please what the [ __ ] are
they yeah so this is another leader
saying there what da [ __ ] dude playing
is like a violin I would break your
violin in half you know what that also
means that they already intended to do
this to travel without instruments
that's how I do but I'm not going to
travel with a drum set and that's night
I was intended to play it hello friends
I traveled her from Kazakhstan
hitchhiking now I need money for [ __ ]
you bro get a job yeah you need money
get a job dude obviously don't have a
job so I can't wait to bring a guitar in
it ah yeah he has a [ __ ] amp with the
foot saw the AB dude tell the guitar oh
[ __ ] yeah I understand those like
[ __ ] wannabe hippie asses but these
older ladies oh my god I expect on a you
know more maturity out of them why do
you think it they think it's okay I have
no idea my boy they're older right
that's like me going into a little
Korres village and then asking them to
support me because I want to be a
musician and buy my trumpet it's like
her backpack is probably someone in that
country's like an entire monthly wage
yeah just like a 2 or $300 u.s. backpack
and then she's going to ask someone
that's there like Foreman it's so crazy
to me
yeah what's exactly acceptable out there
that they're like oh yeah this is this
is normal behavior they should probably
close their border you can even if they
got like
let's say they got mugged and like all
of them all their money is gone yeah
they could go and do something yeah I
can identify this at all
how do you free load off of someone
that's poor to me that's the part that I
don't yeah yeah I don't understand that
you think they find it like they're
super light-hearted and they're like oh
this will be cool like if a good
experience bros like you come with
nothing
yeah a community helping community you
know it'll be a cool challenge if we
just travel the world with nothing but
the clothes on her back yeah that's what
they're thinking
so a Malaysian woman who studied in
political economics she's saying that
the tourists often feel that they can
behave however they want while traveling
to it and exotic exactly that's exactly
what it's like they're going into the
wilderness it's like what [ __ ]
[ __ ] is that I think if they're if
you're in Asia and you're watching this
decade I think you should next time you
see them they're second base walk up to
those [ __ ] and be like what the [ __ ]
man you [ __ ] entitled piece of [ __ ]
get the [ __ ] outta my country sack of
money get out of my country yeah treat
them how dumpers treat everybody else
yeah be an Asian Trumper yeah take their
[ __ ] asses out then that is crave is
to there's not like a running away for
like political asylum dude like what the
[ __ ] where are we here on vacation you
saw trap they're literally on vacation
that's [ __ ] crazy to me if you were
there and you saw that would you
approach these people yeah if they spoke
English I was serious to get the [ __ ]
yeah what if I went to France or Germany
or whatever and I said hey I'm on
vacation and I need a little bit of
change I will cause a [ __ ] scene no
one's going to give me [ __ ] yeah well
when you guys travel to your did you
guys see a lot of panhandlers no yeah
they're native to the country I've never
seen tourists panhandlers ever under
actually street hustlers they're at
least trying to sell a rose sell a toy
they're trying to sell something they're
not just asking for money playing songs
is right here it's homeless on the side
they're not really asking they're just
there and if you so happen to give them
some yeah actually just kind of sell
[ __ ] and make I wonder where their front
because one of that's a mechanic stand
some other people from year I think they
like your pn2 help they're not American
if you're [ __ ] American you need to
get your [ __ ] lunch together God
they're not
maybe they're sprinkled in there
somewhere in the photos they refer to
them as Westerners so that could be yeah
man I this is like blowing my mind like
I can't believe this [ __ ] is even real
the old ladies I was holding the sign
they're actually holding signs up in
Hong Kong and the sign three please help
me money for ticket home thank you maybe
it's a suck my dick I'll give you some
money
awesome irresponsible [ __ ] I know I know
straight up rude that's like me going to
Mexico and asking like a poor ass kid
that's working out like a street taco
stand he can give me some money because
I would like to buy some Nikes if they
had a little bit more decency
I don't even know if this is correct but
ah they would be like let's interrogate
I mean at least that show that they have
some humility and shame because at this
point you have a sign that said I'm on
vacation this is a choice and I'm trying
to have fun
give me money for having fun and love
you you [ __ ] piece of [ __ ] I hope you
get stabbed
oh no I'm sorry I hope so yeah the
pictures that they have they're like
really proud of it actually yeah they're
smiling and having a circus entitled
appspot just that's like you you're
spitting of somebody's [ __ ] face you
piece of [ __ ] I want you to die from the
standing bow like when you get stabbed
and won or not I just want you to get a
little infection and he gets it treated
with antibiotics and then I go make some
more to pay the medical bills maybe
hopefully like the government can step
in and they kicked him out of the
country like the Singapore karate team
comes out just I fell because I know
like in Singapore like if you [ __ ] up
with one of the lot they can kick you
right out so I hope like the government
can step in and say get the [ __ ] out of
the country I'm pretty sure they didn't
even think of a law to say no more
panhandling like what the [ __ ] people
usually want tourists to come to the
country because the dream money they're
going to bring money they're gonna you
know pay for things and stimulate the
economy they don't ever think you'd what
these tourists are going to come into
our country and sucked a [ __ ] economy
out of it yeah no one thinks that well
they're crazy they should pick them out
that's not acceptable
thanks for watching just kidding news
guys don't forget to comment down below
we want to hear what you say only if
it's positive remember that to watch
more videos go up here baby bird
Phoebe
[Music]